[موسيقى]
هذا
العقار هنا الكوكايين يساوي
دولارًا 150. إنه مخدر مدمن يستخدمه الجميع
الكوكايين ،
لديّ كوكايين كراك ، يمكنك تدخينه ،
هذا يساوي
50 30 20.
إنه يسمى k2 وهذا حوالي 15 دولارًا
يدخنها الناس
هذا واحد حصلت عليه ثانيةً أكبر ، أنا
فقط لطيف ،
يمكنك العثور على هذه الأدوية في أي مدينة
في الولايات المتحدة التي تريدها
طالما أنك
تريد الحصول عليها ، هذا ما أفعله ، فأنا أكسب
المال
وأنت تعرف أن هذا ما أفعله كل يوم
بشكل أساسي  تأتي الكثير من الأدوية من
أمريكا الجنوبية عبر المكسيك من خلال أي
دول أخرى تعرف أنها يمكن أن
تمر عبرها وفي كل مرة يتم
فيها بيعها أو قطعها أو
حتى تصبح أقل وأقل وأقل قوة ،
وبحلول الوقت الذي تحصل فيه  إلى مستوى الشارع
في مدن معينة ، لم يكن قريبًا
من القوة التي كانت عليه عندما كان من
المؤكد أنك تعرف
أن عملية الاتجار مستمرة طوال
الوقت وهناك العديد من الطرق المختلفة التي
يضعها الناس في فتحة الشرج في
الواقي الذكري.
أم خشب  en
الشكل الذي قد يكون تذكارًا ،
يمكنك قصه إلى نصفين مجوفًا
وملئه بكيس من الكوكايين أو أي شيء
ثم ختمه احتياطيًا بالورنيش ،
إنه تذكار من أي مكان
ذهبت إليه للناس الذين يركضون لهم من
خلال
ما  دعا البغل ، لذلك لديك
شخص ما يديره ، لذا فإن الشخص
الذي يشتريه لديه شخص ما
سيواجه مشكلة في الأساس
للاتجار به على متن طائرة أو أي شيء يتم
إحضاره بهذه الطريقة
ومرة أخرى يتم تخطيه أكثر  وأكثر وأكثر
مع مرور الوقت ، لكن الشيء هو أنه لا يمكنك
إيقافه طالما أن الناس يريدون ذلك ،
أعني الآن أن الناس في أمريكا يأخذون
منظف الغسيل المد والجزر ، وفي الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي
قاموا
بشم الغراء ، أعني أنهم ما زالوا يفعلون ذلك ولكن
أي شيء يغير نظرتك
وهي مشكلة طوال
الوقت وليست دائمًا فقط المخدرات هي
التي ستفسدك
بل إنها كل الأشياء الخطيرة
التي
تدور حولهم العنف
لأن هذا المال هو مشغول  نيس
وإذا عبثت بها يمكن
أن تقتل
[موسيقى]
ربما تكون الماريجوانا هي الأقل
هجومًا لأنها تؤثر على
الناس بطرق مختلفة يصاب بها
بعض الناس بجنون العظمة مثل الرجل
الذي توقف ست مرات في محطة واحدة إشارة إلى أن
بعض الناس يشعرون بالدوار والضحك
والسعادة والجوع يمنحك الكوكايين
دفعة كبيرة من
الطاقة وأنت فقط تشعر بالقوة
ويمكنك فعل أي شيء وترتفع ثقتك بنفسك
وكل ذلك
يمكنني أن أفهم لماذا
يتعاطى الناس الكوكايين لكن الآخرين ينزلون من تعاطي الكوكايين.
شراء quaaludes التي
يتم ابتلاعها هو
دواء للسرطان لوقف الألم ،
لذا إذا كان الناس يأخذون quaaludes
[موسيقى] فقد
ذهبت للتو ،
فأنت مجرد متعب ، فأنت فقط في منطقة خالية من
الهيروين لها نفس التأثير وكنت
أتساءل دائمًا  عن الهيروين لماذا تفعل
لماذا تأخذ شيئًا يأخذك بعيدًا
ولكني عرفت شخصًا أخذ
الهيروين وسألته وقالوا لأنه عندما
تتناول الهيروين
لا تواجه أي مشاكل كل شيء على ما يرام ،
فقط تجلس  في الزاوية وسيل لعابك على
نفسك وربما
لكن لا تقلق بشأن أي شيء
كل شيء على ما يرام
كل شيء على ما يرام ومرة أخرى يعود كل شيء إل
تغيير حا
تك العقلية والعاطفية لماذا يف
ل الناس هذا ويغيرون حا
تهم العقلية هم
لست سعيدًا
[موسيقى]
هناك مخدرات في كل مكان إذا كنت
تدخل
معظم الحانات وتسأل فقط عما إذا كنت تريد بعض
الهيروين تريد بعض الكوكايين
وتريد بعض الكراك تريد أي شيء
كهذا تريد أقراصًا
مقابل المال حصلت عليه أنت "  سأجد الناس
بسرعة كبيرة ،
إنه موجود في كل مكان ، إنه موجود في كل
مكان تعرف أنه
يمكنني الحصول عليه ، يمكنني الحصول على أي مخدرات
لأخبرك أنني أفعل هذا كما تعلم ،
أعني أنني سأموت من أجل هذا ،
أنا لا أبيع المخدرات بسبب
ابنتي ، لا أنا  أنا لا أتعامل
معها ، أنا أحتج بنفسي ، أنا أعبث مع
الرؤساء الشرعيين حتى يفهمني الناس
لأنك تعرف ما أعنيه أنني لن أقصد أن أقوم
باختصار لك ، أنا لست مثل ذلك الذي أحاول
تحسينه  كم من التحيز يمكن أن
أتذكره  أخبرتك ri أن لدي بعض القواعد ،
فالقاعدة الأولى لا تقلل من شأن أي شخص مطلقًا
، وتذكر القاعدة الثانية
أن كل فعل سيكون
هناك رد فعل
رقم 11 لا تدع عدوك يعرف أبدًا
ما تفكر فيه
رقم 12 ، الرجل الوحيد الذي يجب إطعامه
هو الله
جيدًا يقولون  أن لديهم الكثير
ليفعلوه مع العصابات
وهذا ما يلومونه على الكثير
من نشاط العصابات
الذي يدخلونه هناك في سن 10
سنوات وأنا أعلم أنهم لا يدركون حقًا
ما يدفعون بأنفسهم إلى سبب
محاولتهم  العثور على عائلة لأن الكثيرين
منهم
إما أنهم بدون أب أو
بدون أم
، ولذا فهم مرتبطون بشيء
مع ذلك لأنهم يريدون أسرة
يريدونهم يريدون شخصًا
يشعرون فيه أنهم يحبونهم
لذلك يخرجون في  في الشارع وتجده
عندما تدخل في عصابة
تشعر وكأنك جزء من شيء ما ،
لذلك أعتقد أنه
في كثير من الأحيان إلى أين على الرغم من
أن هذه هي المشكلة في
أنهم ليس لديهم طعام نصفهم
لا يفعلون ذلك  ر  ليس لديهم سقف فوق
رؤوسهم ،
لذلك هذا ما سيفعلونه ،
فبعضهم ليس لديهم أي مهارات للعمل ،
لذلك سيسرقون
أنهم سيقتلون بعضهم البعض
كما تعلمون نصف رأسي.  المخدرات
سيئة للغاية ، لقد حصلنا على وباء المخدرات
لأرمل الكثير من الشباب هنا حيث
ظهرت الحبوب التي تفرقع الحبوب تأخذ
أموالًا ، وهذا له علاقة كبيرة بها
أيضًا للعناية بهذه العادة المخدرة
التي يحتاجون إليها في المنزل أكثر إيجابية  إنهم
بحاجة إلى
المزيد من الرجال ، والمزيد من الرجال ليخرجوا ليريوهم
ويظهروا لهم ما يفعلونه ، ولا يوضحوا
لهم كيفية بيع المخدرات ، وضح لهم
كيف ينهضون ويذهبون للحصول على وظيفة
عن طريق عرض نماذج لأنفسهم سيحصلون على
وظيفة مقابل الوقوف في الزاوية  لذا
فهم بحاجة إلى المزيد من القادة ليخرجوا
إلى هناك لمساعدتهم على
سحق الأنظمة ،
فالأفراد ليسوا مصممين
لمحاربة الأنظمة
حتى شركة حتى حكومة مدينة
إذا كنت لا ترغب في إنشاء عالم جديد ،
فعليك أن تجعل
أشخاصًا جددًا هم نفس الأشخاص  التي تفعل
الأشياء القديمة
لا يمكنها إجراء انتقال جديد
ما لم يغيروا رأيهم
وقلوبهم ،
فهذا ما نعنيه
بالتطور على الثورة ،
نرى التطور يستغرق فترة طويلة
من الزمن
عقودًا وقرونًا ، لذلك يجب على الإنسان
أن يتطور من أجل
صنع عالم أفضل
كيف تفعل يا أخي كيف  أنت تشعر
اليوم ،
أنا بخير ، هل أنت
من هوموود ،
أنا من صخرة طفل ، صخور المفاتيح ،
حسنًا ، ما هي نظرتك ،
أعني أنني أحاول فقط رعاية
ابنتي واه
أنت تعرف المحاولة  لإيجاد طريقة لأكون
في
المكان الذي أريد أن أكون فيه في الحياة ، فأنت تعلم
أين هذا المكان المناسب
لبدء
مثل
الأثرياء ، هذا فقط ما يعنيه الغني
أنك حصلت على ما تريد ، كل ما
تحتاجه ، وجبات
خفيفة دقيقة ودقيقة  لقد حصلت على
ما تريد ، هذا ما تحتاجه ، لذا
سترى بشكل خاص أن ريتشارد لديه
مبلغ معين من المال ، ثم نعم ،
ليس من الضروري دائمًا أن يكون مبلغًا معينًا
من المال ،
لكنني أعني أنك يجب أن تعيش ثريًا ،
ما الذي يعنيه هذا يعني  أنت  يجب أن
يكون كل شيء
كما لو كنت تعرف جيدًا عنك ، أنت تعرف جيدًا ،
أعني أن
كل شيء يمكن أن يكون هناك لا يمكن أن يكون
هناك
أخطاء ، هناك الكثير من المال الذي تعرفه
اعتني بابنتي ،
لذا ما الذي تخبرني به ما
أنت على الطريق  تعتقد أنك ستصل إلى
هناك على
ما يرام ، يعتقد المحتال أن الصخب هو أن
الناس يفعلون ذلك فقط للحصول على أموال إضافية ،
والجميع يريد الحصول على أموال إضافية
والاستمرار في
كسب المال كل دقيقة من اليوم ،
لكنني أعني
أنك يجب أن أعني أنه يمكنك الذهاب إلى  السجن ،
صحيح ، هذا هو الشيء الوحيد الذي
تعرفه ، أعني الشيء الوحيد
الذي هو الشيء الوحيد الذي هو
أساسًا بطريقة ما هو أن الشيء الوحيد
في الطريقة
نعم أعرف الكثير من المحتالين في القبر
أيضًا على الرغم من
أنك قلت ابنتك على الرغم من  حسنًا ، نعم
ابنتك ، صحيح ،
إذا كنت في السجن عندما كنت ميتًا ،
أين تركت ابنتك
ثم هي أكبر جزء من
اللغز
جيدًا ، فأنت تعلم أنها مخطئة ، أعني إذا كنت
ميتًا ، فأنا أعني
أنه لا يوجد شيء يمكنني القيام به  يعني أنا
علمتها الكثير ،
لذا إذا مت ، فستكون ذكية ،
كيف يمكنها القيام بالكثير من الأشياء خمسة ، حسنًا
،
إنها تعرف أشياء أيضًا لأنها تعرف الكثير
من الأشياء
التي تعتقد أنها تعرفها بما يكفي الآن لتعيش
حياتها بدونك من أجل  بقية حياتها ،
أعني أنها حصلت على
لعبة والدتنا الآن أنت تعمل من أجل
اللعبة الآن هناك مائة قطط أخرى ،
لذا نفس العقلية التي تحاول
فعل الشيء نفسه الذي تحاول
أن تفعله بنفس الطريقة التي تحاول بها
افعلها تشعرني وكل ما لا يمكنك الفوز به
أنت تعلم ، أعني أنني أعلم
أنك ستصبح الشخص الذي يفوز الآن
أنا لست غاضبًا منك لأنك تعلم
أنني أقصد  يجب أن تشعر وكأنك
ستفوز إذا كنت في اللعبة ،
ما أقوله لك هو أنك بحاجة إلى
قلب اللعبة ،
كان هذا بعضًا من طاقمي ، هذا أحد
رفاقي ، هذا
ظرف يخدم الحياة بالإضافة إلى 20  في
سجن شديد
الحراسة تحت الأرض ، كان على
شيء يسمى لا يوجد اتصال بشري هذا
آه
يا رجلي كان كبيرًا جي
ًا  لقد تم إطلاق النار عليه ، كان هذا كونغ فو ، لقد
كان أحد حراستي الشخصية ،
كان عليه أن
يغادر المدينة
حتى لا يعود هذا أحد
رفاقي ، كان مثل أحد ثيرانتي
، كان أحد مقاتلي  هذا ليل
نيللي ، انتهى به الأمر بمحاربة هذا الرجل
، وسحب الرجل منه 380
وأطلق النار عليه مرة واحدة وأصيب
بالشلل من الرقبة إلى أسفل ولكن كل
هؤلاء الرجال ماتوا
باستثناء اثنين.
وكان هذا أنا كما تعلم ،
هذا أنا جيدًا مثل 19. كان هذا أنا
في 21 عامًا ،
كنت معروفًا باسم تيد مجنون لأن أحدهم
هو أنني كنت معروفًا بحمل
أسلحة كبيرة ، مثل تلك التي كانت
بندقية مقطوعة
وهو أمر غير واقعي بعض الشيء للاستمرار به
على أساس يومي لأنه
كبير جدًا لدرجة
أنني كنت بحاجة إلى أن يعتقد الناس أنني
سأذهب إلى أبعد
ما يمكن أن يأخذني إليه أي شخص ، إنه أمر مضحك
لأنني معروف  كما دكتور تيد سوتون الآن ولكن إذا بحثت في
جوجل
بجنون ، سيظهر وجهي
ويبدو أنه كان شيئًا ما  كانت القبعة
جيدة للدخول
إليك ، أعلم أننا كنا شعبًا شعبيًا عرفنا أن
كل هذه الأشياء هي أشياء
حدثت لنا في سن
مبكرة ، ولذا فقد أتيحت لي الفرصة لأعيش الحياة
تقريبًا كشخص أكبر سنًا في سن مبكرة
أحملها بالفعل  هذه الصور من حولي
لأنك تعلم أنه في بعض الأحيان يجب أن يتم تذكيرك
بأنك تعلم أنه تم إعطائي فرصة ثانية في
معظم الحالات التي أتعامل معها تشمل
عنف المخدرات وأشياء من هذا القبيل
وأن المال هو الغرض من المخدرات
الأعمال التجارية لديك الكثير من الأفراد
الذين تم اختراقهم نتيجة لذلك ، على
سبيل المثال ضابط إصلاحية
مكلف بجلب المخدرات إلى المنشأة
التي دفعها أفراد في الشارع
لإحضار هذه المخدرات وغيرها من المواد
المهربة
إلى النظام الذي كان عليه  تم القبض عليك
نتيجة التنصت
، وهذا في محكمة الولاية ، لديك أيضًا
النظام الفيدرالي
الذي يخشى أكثر من أولئك
المتورطين في السلوك الإجرامي في الشارع
لأنه في النظام الفيدرالي
لديهم الكثير من
التحقيقات بدلاً من مجرد ضابط الإيقاع الذي يركض
حول القبض على رجل
في الشارع بحيث يكون لديهم التنصت على المكالمات الهاتفية
لديهم المخبرين السريين
في القضايا الفيدرالية والعقوبات
أيضًا
أكبر بكثير وبالتالي يخشى معظم الأفراد
من التورط
في النظام الفيدرالي حسنًا ،
هناك الكثير من الظلم في النظام
الذي لا يفهمه بشكل صحيح
، وبالتالي لديك الكثير من
الأبرياء الذين تمت
إدانتهم بعد منحهم الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة في
بعض الأحيان ، وللأسف ، تأتي هذه الإدانة على
أنها  نتيجة
لأعمال النيابة العامة غير القانونية أو
إجراءات الشرطة ، وفي بالتيمور رأينا مؤخرًا
عددًا من ضباط الشرطة الذين
تورطوا في
سلوك إجرامي أدى إلى
إدانة أشخاص آخرين
وإرسالهم إلى السجن ، وهذه مشكلة كبيرة
لأن المجتمع يفقد أي ثقة قليلة
لديهم
في النظام هم بالتأكيد يعملون على
الإحصائيات ،
إنه مقياس لمدى جودة ضابط الشرطة
لقد قمت بالاعتقالات التي قمت بها ،
وإذا كان من الممكن أن يكون ذلك لبندقية
وكمية كبيرة من المخدرات ، فهذا
أفضل حتى من
وجود حافز لاعتقال الأشخاص
حتى لو لم يكونوا مذنبين
منذ فريدي جراي قبل بضع سنوات
رأينا بعض الشيء  عكس ذلك
لأن شعور الضابط هو أنه
يمكن مقاضاتهم بأنفسهم
لقيامهم بالاعتقالات
التي اعتبروها مشروعة ، وبالتالي ، حيث
اعتاد العديد منهم على
التصرف بشكل استباقي ، كان
العديد منهم الآن يجلسون في الخلف
ويقضون ثماني ساعات ويذهبون إلى
المنزل  وهكذا ، فقد رأيت في بالتيمور
أنه نوع من تقليص النفقات فيما
يتعلق بالاعتقال ، ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالمخدرات
والأسلحة التي يحصلون عليها
، فإن هذه
الاعتقالات دائمًا ما تكون مستمرة ،
لذلك إذا كنت تعلم أن معظم  الناس
في هذا الحي الذين يتاجرون
بالمخدرات هم من
السود وهذا مجرد حقيقة
بسبب سجلات الاعتقال
، سيكون من السخف القول إنني
سأتجاهل ذلك لأنني لا أريد أن أكون
عنصريًا  إعادة التحيز وهكذا دائمًا
ما يكون دائمًا مثل ما يمكنك رؤيته ،
لذا إذا أوقفت شخصًا ما وأعلمك
أن جذعًا مليئًا بالهيروين ، فمن
المحتمل أن يكون
أه مسلحًا خطيرًا ولا يريد حقًا
أن يكون
أه سيُسجن من أجل هذا جيدًا
قد يرغب في قتلك وقد يكون
مسلحًا جيدًا بشكل أفضل مما أنت عليه
، لذلك قد يكون
لديك 45 ولديه بندقية هجومية من طراز AK-47
يمكنها
تفجير سيارتك ،
ولا يمكنك التخلص من أي شيء
غير قانوني أي شيء  غير قانوني
فقط أه لا يزال هناك فرص
للشراء
، إذا كان هناك 20 سيارة في طريقها
، فمن المحتمل أن يكون هناك إطلاق نار ،
فقد يكون هناك قتال في
الحانة خرج عن نطاق السيطرة حقًا ، ولكن إذا كنت ترى
أن العديد من السيارات يمكن أن يكون هناك إطلاق
نار  طعن
أي شخص يمكن أن يذهب إلى السجن في أي وقت ، ولكن
عندما تضع نفسك في وضع
تكون فيه معرضًا لخطر أكبر ،
فمن المرجح أن يحدث لك أكثر من
شخص آخر ، يجب أن يكون لديك أي شخص
ولكن لا يمكنك التبرير مع نفسك
بالقول  يمكن أن h  appen أي شخص بشكل صحيح
لأنه يمكن ذلك ،
ولكن إذا كنت تصارع وكنت
على الزاوية ويحاول شخص ما
سرقة
احتمالية أن يتم إطلاق النار عليك بدلاً
من أن يتم إطلاق النار علي أثناء عملي في العمل ،
فهذا أعلى منك بعشر مرات
صحيح أن الجميع يعرفون
ما يريدون فعله في الحياة ،
لذلك كنت في الثامنة عشر من
عمري. كما تعلم ، أعني أن لدي عصابتي ، لقد فعلنا ما نفعله ،
نعم ، أنا أقول
الآن أنني كنت أكثر عضلات لم أكن
محتال صخب ابني
بقيت في المال لأن رجلي كان
يتزاحم كما تعلمون ما أقوله ،
لكنه وصل إلى مكان حيث
اختفى من طاقمي ثلاث قطط
وأنا معجب كما تعلمون ، أعني
أنني موجود بالفعل  هذا ما تشعرني به ، لقد وصل
إلى
مكان تعرف أنه كان علي أن أقرر ما أريده
وما الذي سيحصل لي على ما
أريده ولم يكن هوستون سيفعل ذلك ،
ولم يكن سيحصل علي
حتى أحصل  طرقت في المرة القادمة التي تشعر فيها
حتى سرقني أحدهم في المرة القادمة ،
نعم ، أعني أن أموالي كانت منخفضة ،
فأنا دائمًا في نقطة
لم يسرقها أحد  أنا حسنًا ، أعني أنه
قد لا يطلق النار عليك ، ثم تشعر بأنني
أسلك طريقين مختلفين للوصول إلى هناك ،
فأنت تعلم ما أقوله
، والآخر لديه مخاطر عالية والآخر لديه مخاطر منخفضة ،
كما تعلم إذا كنت تشعر
بذلك  الشيء الخاص بي هو أنك تحتاج إلى العثور
على طريق أقل مقاومة ، فأنت تعلم
ما أقوله أنه سيوصلك إلى حيث
تريد
دون إضافة هذا القدر من المخاطرة ، فأنت تعرف
ما أعنيه لأن آخر شيء
تريده هو  أمي لتنظر إلى
النعش الخاص بك ،
بدأت في التسكع مع بعض هؤلاء
الرجال عندما كنت مثل 15
ألعب كرة السلة كما تعلمون في
مشاريع ملاعب لافاييت
في المنطقة مشاريع شرفة ليكسينغتون
كانت المشكلة الحقيقية هي أنه
عندما تحيط نفسك بالناس
من يفكر على حد سواء ولكن كل شخص
يفكر في بعض الأشياء المجنونة ، لا
يبدو أنه مجنون ،
إنه نوع من تطبيع الجنون
لأن الجميع يفكرون في
نفس الشيء الذي
كنا نقارن فيه البنادق ،
ما نوع البندقية التي حصلت عليها ، أي نوع من الأسلحة حصلت عليه
جيدًا  أنا أخذت  هذا
يا رجل ، لقد حصلت على بيضة الصحراء ،
فلا يوجد شيء سأكون مثله يا رجل ، لقد حصلت
على غلوك مع نقطة الليزر
ولذا فقد تطبيع الجنون
حيث يقول شخص ما هذا
مجنون ولن نفعل ذلك  قل أنه من الجنون
أن أكون مثل ناه هذا يوم الثلاثاء ،
لذلك كان لدي آباء جيدون كانا
أبوين إيجابيين كانا في داخلك
تعرف الكنيسة
ولكن بعد ذلك عندما ذهبت إلى المدرسة لمدة
ثماني ساعات تعاملت مع
أشخاص لا يفكرون  بهذه الطريقة وبعد ذلك
عندما غادرت المنزل من المدرسة ،
تعاملت مع بضع ساعات أخرى بعد ذلك ،
لذلك نحن في المشاريع
وأنت تعلم أننا هنا نوعًا ما ، فأنت تعلم أن
شخصًا ما يقول شيئًا ما يا رجل ما
تنظر إليه ما تنظر
إليه لتكون صادقًا معه  أنت بالنسبة لي ،
نظر إليها الجميع على أنها
المزيد من الحماية ، فأنت لا تريد حقًا
الدخول في
معركة بالأسلحة النارية بسكين ، سنضع
المسدس أرضًا إذا كان الرجل التالي
سيضع المسدس أرضًا ،
وهذا نوع من العقلية
التي  كان معها ،
لذلك ربما كانت بعض العصابات الأخرى
أطقم أخرى هناك بعض الأحياء الأخرى
هنا في بالتيمور أولاً تم تقسيم
شرق بالتيمور وغرب بالتيمور هذا
خارج العضلات وكان لدي رجال
تعرفهم في تلك المنطقة
الآن يبدو أن اللعبة قد
غيرت بالتأكيد
القاعدة كانت المال أولاً  ضع الورق فوق
كل شيء طالما أنني أصنع
الورق ، يمكنني بيعه لتلك الفتاة
الحامل ، يمكنني
بيعها للأطفال في
مدرسة إعدادية كما تعلمون
قائلة إنني أستطيع فعل أشياء معينة وأسألهم
أنني بخير  ثم أخبرني ما
هو رقمك ، لقد قالوا جيدًا ، ما
هو رقمك الذي
تعنيه وقلت أخبرني عندما تصل إلى هذا
الرقم بصفتك تاجر مخدرات عندما تخرج
هنا
أي أموال تفعلها مهما فعلت
لتكسب paypal هنا  تخبرني الشوارع
عندما تصل إلى ذلك ، هل
ستستقيل
مثل هل هو عشرة آلاف دولار خمسة عشر
ألف دولار
وخمسون ألف دولار ومائة
ألف دولار ما هي
خطة الخروج الخاصة بك لأنك ترى إذا لم تفعل هذا
يعني أنك لا تفعل ذلك  ليس لديك خطة خروج
مما يعني أنك تنتظر
الأولاد الذين يقفزون
أو تنتظر شخصًا
تعرفه يخرجك من هذا
الأمر ، وهذا يعني أنك تنتظر حتى يتم
حبسك أو الخروج  قتل ،
وهذا يعني بالتأكيد أن شيئًا
ما حدث للتو
كما تعلمون هنا وهو جديد قليلاً
أيضًا ، لذا لم يكن لديهم حتى شريط ،
لكن
هذا كان بالتأكيد مسرح جريمة
إطلاق نار
[موسيقى
] حصلت على صديق أنني ذهبت إلى المدرسة
مع الكلية ، إنه طبيب
، يجعل أي صخب تعرفه أكثر من أي شيء ،
وهو لا يكافح من
أجلي ، لذا أعني أنه إذا كان الأمر يتعلق
بالورقة ، فهذا ما أعنيه أن هناك وظائف
يمكن أن تحصل على الورقة التي تريدها والتي
لا تريدها.  لا داعي للصخب
ولكن عليك أن تصارع للحصول على هذه الوظيفة
، تشعرني أنه نشأ في عائلة مثلما
ذهبنا إلى الكلية وأكلنا نودلز رامين كل
يوم تشعرني ، ثم كان مقيمًا ،
نعم أعني أنه شق طريقه في
هذه القطة  جعل 250 ساعة سنويًا
مجانيًا وشرعيًا لقد صنعت أكثر من 250 ساعة
أعرفها  هذا
ولكن كيف ستضاعف
هذا حيث يرتكب معظم المحتالين أخطاء
في الوقت المناسب ، تقلب لتناول الطعام في اليوم
إذا ربحت 250000 في السنة ، فلن تحصل على
أي شيء في نهاية
العام كان استثمارًا سيئًا على الرغم من أن هذا
ما هذا هو ما يدور حولك
مقامرًا أو يمكنك أن تخسره على
الإطلاق وتظل محتالًا وتستعيده مرة أخرى
، ولم تكن هذه هي وجهتي ، أنا هنا فقط ،
هذا ما أنا هنا من أجله مثل
هذا في
الأساس  في الأساس ،
تركت الحياة تحدث
لك ، ولم تأخذها في الأساس ، فأنت لم
تستحوذ على الحياة ، لأن الحياة
حدثت بشكل أساسي الآن ، أنت الآن
قادم إليّ للتو ، لكنك تركب
موجة  مكان سيء للعيش فيه بإخوانه ،
يمكنك الركوب
بعيدًا ولكن يمكنك أن تقرر على الرغم من لا ، ولكن
يمكنك أن تقرر ما الذي يكسب المال
إذا لم يكن لديك أي شيء في
نهاية اليوم ،
نعم ، أعني إذا كانت حياتك كلها
مقامرة كما تعلم  ما أعنيه وأنت
تبحث دائمًا
عن العقدة الكبيرة التالية للحصول على الوجه
كما تعلم ، أعني لي  إنك لا تقلب
إلى أي شيء ، نعم ، أنا أقول أن
هذا هو الرقم إذا كنت محتالًا
فستكسب بعض المال ولكن هذا هو
الخطأ الجسدي الذي يرتكبه المحتال
هو أنك تعيش فقط في الوقت الحالي نعم
وفي النهاية  من اليوم
الذي سمحت فيه لك في اليوم الذي لا تعيش فيه
بشيء مثل أنك ميت
ولا شيء ، أنت
مبهرج وأنت لا تشعر بالسعادة أبدًا ، فأنت
تفهم ما أقوله أنه لا يمكنك أبدًا
تحقيق
ما لا يمكنك تحقيقه  لا يمكنك أبدًا تحقيق
السعادة بهذه الطريقة على الرغم من
أنه ليس لديك أي شيء ،
فأنت دائمًا ما تقلبه دائمًا ، فأنت
دائمًا ما تكون على
أعناقك ، فأنت دائمًا تبحث عن
لعقك التالي ، فأنت تشعر
بأنك لم تصل أبدًا إلى مكان تتواجد فيه  يمكن أن نقول ،
دعنا نذهب في إجازة ،
تشعرني ، دعنا نذهب مستلقين على الشاطئ ،
لا يمكنني فعل ذلك لأنك
تخمن دائمًا ما تكون دائمًا في
وضع الوجه ، لا يمكنك أن تقول
نعم
ولكني  أريد أن أفعل هذه الأشياء ، لكن الأمر
أشبه بالبقاء في
بيتسبرغ لأنني لا أريد الذهاب إلى أي مكان  في
أي مكان
لدي ، هذه هي لعبة البيسبول كما أريد
أن أكون في بيتسبرغ
ويمكنك الصخب بنفس القدر من الناحية القانونية
أتمنى أن يكون
بإمكاني أن أجعل
حياة المخدرات عملاً شرعيًا دون أن
يلامس أي جسم أي شيء مثله  فقط
كن حرفيًا ما أقوله لك على
الرغم من أنني أتحدث عن
نسيان المخدرات مثل المخدرات أولاً وقبل كل شيء
تدمير
صيدلية جمال صحيح أفراد عائلتك في
مجتمعك ، لذا انسى المخدرات ولكن
هذا لا يساعدني يجب أن أساعدك أو
لا أحد
هذا ما أنا عليه ، هذا ما
أحتاجه للقيام بهذا ما أنا في طريقي
لفقد 40 قططًا من عمري 40
عامًا ، عمري 40 عامًا ، لقد فقدت 40 قططًا من الوقت الذي كنت
فيه
12 حتى الآن ، أنت تعرف ما أعنيه أن
البعض كان لديه أموال كبيرة الكثير من الناس ، لذلك
الكثير من الأصدقاء المقربين
الذين اعتدت أن أتسكع معهم ولكن هل يمكن أن
يؤذي الأمر إلى الصفر
لأنك لا تستطيع الوثوق بالناس
لأنك تستطيع  يمكنك اتخاذ قرار
اليوم والقول إنني
أستطيع ولكن هذا ليس صحيحًا
سيجعلني أشعر بالضيق تجاه n  لا تفعل ما أريد
مثل كيف ما أقوله مثل لماذا لا تستطيع أن
تفعل
ما تريده هو أن أكون محتال وهذا
ما تفضله بدلاً من
تقويمه ،
ما زلت سأكون  محتال في رجل
العصابات أو أيا كان ، لكنني
عادة شرعي ، لذا فأنا ما زلت سأستمر في
فعل ذلك واستمر في فعل
ذلك
حتى أكون في السجن مدى الحياة
أنت